[Music]
well don't forget that Bruno
rocked the Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show last year and tomorrow night in
Shanghai it's Harry Styles turn
we've got your exclusive with Harry
backstage where he reveals his own very
interesting style inspiration I think
both my music and fashion main influence
was for Shania Twain man-woman things
he's amazing
now that he mentions it we can kind of
see it and we know he means it because
we caught Harry rocking out to some
Shania before hitting the runway to open
the show I mean I've never played a
fashion show before so it's a privilege
it's definitely no fun to be here music
is a big part of this show on stage and
behind the scenes it's how angel Lily
Aldridge calls her pre-show jitters the
playlist well it doesn't include hubby
Caleb Followill x'b and Kings of Leon
but her bestie Taylor oh she's on it
what are you listening to the Hamilton
soundtrack yes and I'm also listening to
Miguel's song and Harry Styles song and
I also have Taylor Swift album but for
fellow angel Adriana Lima
her backstage ritual it's a personal
note he's no laughs it's it's oh for
Tanaka Munna Bhai Rana
let me tell you why this on this
important to me my first fashion show I
was 16 years old I walk with a song to
this day every show that I walk I listen
to this